major news from the world of the Elector
revolts against president-elect Donald
Trump let me quickly catch you up on
November 31st last week I came to you
and told you that a personal source of
mine indicated that 15 Trump electors
were planning to vote not for Donald
Trump on the vote that will be taken on
December nineteenth that video doing
okay on youtube with about 50,000 views
the next day I spoke to a number of
additional people but in particular one
well-placed successful democratic
operative as I referred to them who
confirmed to me that yes indeed there is
a growing Trump electr revolt and that
video achieving about 100,000 views on
YouTube that one was done just as a
YouTube only sort of update and I was
told specifically at the time listen
David there are a number of Trump
electors who have decided not to vote
for Trump on December nineteenth but
they want someone else to publicly
announce this first they don't want to
be the first to sign their name next to
an op-ed for example saying i am a trump
elector who is not voting Trump but I
was told we have the op-ed ready to go
for whoever it is that ultimately wants
to come forward and put their name on it
and go public now one of them has we
have a new york times op-ed released
yesterday in which texas republican
elector christopher supreme says he will
not be voting for Donald Trump on
December nineteenth the first quote I
want to pull out for you from this new
york times op-ed has supreme saying i am
a republican presidential elector one of
the 538 people asked to choose
officially the President of the United
States since the election people have
asked me to change my vote based on
policy disagreements with Donald J Trump
in some cases they cite the popular vote
difference I do not think president
elects should be well I think it's
president-elect it should say should be
disqualified for policy disagreements I
do not think they should be disqualified
because they won the electoral college
instead of the popular vote however now
I am asked to cast a vote on December
night
team for someone who shows daily he is
not qualified for the office and then
supreme goes on to list in this op-ed a
number of actions Trump is taken
attacking TV show cast tweeting day and
night stoking fear creating outrage
having no knowledge of the issues his
cabinet pics being bad and then this
op-ed by this Republican electorate
Texas is wrapped up by saying quote the
election of the next president is not
yet a done deal electors of conscience
can still do the right thing for the
good of the country presidential
electors have the legal right and a
constitutional duty to vote their
conscience I believe electors should
unify behind a Republican alternative
and honorable and qualified man or woman
such as Governor John Kasich of Ohio I
pray my fellow electors will do their
job and join me in discovering who that
person should be 15 years ago I swore an
oath to defend my country and
Constitution against all enemies foreign
and domestic on December 19 I will do it
again this is one Pat we believe there
are many many more and if this revolt is
a big big if if this revolt were to deny
Donald Trump the presidency of course
the right would go nuts saying this
isn't how it's supposed to be but it
actually would be how it's supposed to
be the system would be working because
as we heard about from up so many of the
framers including Hamilton the entire
point of the electoral college is that
it is there to prevent popular
demagogues which is exactly what Donald
Trump is from taking over the country
that's why we have electors who elect
the President yeah i mean the electoral
college is an antiquated system to begin
with in part because the faithless
lectures that is you can be brought up
but this would be a way to right the
wrong i think democrats have been the
ones negatively impacted by the
electoral college into at the last five
elections and this could make up for it
will trump come back at this an attack
this elector christopher supreme i I
hope that he uh doesn't because it would
be unfair but there might be backlash if
he does we're talking about in
Christopher to prune an emergency
response a specialist who was in DC on
911 responded to the 911 attacks
the Pentagon a responder at Hurricane
Katrina has taught at George Washington
University has worked for two governor's
senator the White House we're talking
here Pat about someone who if Trump were
to assail him you would think it would
look terrible but then I remember Trump
is attacked everybody he's attacked the
parents of deceased American soldiers
he's made fun of disabled reporters so
actually maybe there isn't that much
liability if Trump decides to attack
supreme personally I think you would
also be giving more light to this issue
and I think by this guy coming forward
it could spark a whole bunch of others
to come forward and that's where the
issue would take place if they get to
that 30-something necessary number that
that's the idea the obviously one
elector is not going to change anything
even if the number i gave you last week
15 electors flip that is not going to
change anything but the idea here is
that there is clearly a movement that
exists we now have multiple sources have
told me about it and we now have a
specific name christopher supreme to
assign to this and there is every
indication that christopher sapru is not
the only one